morning all we begin with breaking news
a search and rescue operation is
underway in the English Channel now
details are generally still emerging and
this has only been we've only heard
about this in the past couple of hours
but a major incident has been declared
involving a small boat now this is the
point at which Sky News understands it
is unfolding around halfway between the
Kent coast and the coast of France with
multiple agencies involved in search and
rescue uh Sky sabachary joins me and
with the very latest it is the scale of
the effort of the rescue effort that has
really really grabbed me this morning
this is clearly very serious good
morning Noah absolutely it's the
incident as you say we still are yet to
find out more information about what
exactly has gone down but it involves a
small boat just off the coast of Kent
near Dungeness and we have actually got
a statement from a maritime and Coast
Guard agency spokesperson they have said
that the the HM Coast Guard is currently
coordinating a search and rescue
response to an incident in for involving
a small boat off Kent and they are
working with the Navy border Force Kent
Police and with other partners they've
also said that a fishing vessel is in
the area also assisting the rescue
southeast coast ambulance and Kent
Police are working with us and an air
ambulance has been sent the incident is
ongoing they say and we have no further
information at this point now this comes
just hours after the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak promised to bring in new
laws to tackle illegal immigration as
you say this is very serious indeed and
we will have more updates for you as we
get them yeah as soon as anything comes
through you to bring it straight to air
for no Saba thanks very much indeed